>>> OH!
>> LOOK HOW CUTE SHE IS.
>> THIS IS SUCH A GOOD IDEA.
GETTING CATWOMAN A CAT?
>> YEAH, THAT'S A PERFECT GIFT.
>> PLUS, IT'S LIKE --
>> TRULY CLASSIC, YEAH.
>> OH, CUTE CAT.
ZOE'S HERE TO SEE YOU.
>> OH, YEAH, SEND HER ON IN.
>> HEY, ZOE, THEY'RE READY FOR
YOU.
>> OKAY, GREAT, THANKS.
HEY, GUYS.
>> WE LOST THE CAT!
>> WHAT?
>> SHUT THE DOOR, ZOE!
SHUT THE DOOR!
>> SHUT IT, SHUT IT!
CLOSE IT!
>> WAIT, WHAT?
>> IS THAT ALL YOU CAN SAY?
HELP US FIND YOUR GIFT.
>> WHY DID YOU BUY ME A CAT?
>> WE THOUGHT IT WOULD BE FUNNY
TO GET CATWOMAN A WARMING CAT.
>> IT'S CLASSIC.
>> IT'S ENTERTAINING, OKAY?
WE GOT ANT-MAN A MAN ANT.
>> COME ON.
>> WAIT, STOP, NO.
STOP.
THIS IS INSANE.
WHAT'S THE BIG DEAL?
>> YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND.
THE CAT'S NAME IS SNUGGLEBUCKET
AND IT LOOKS LIKE THIS.
>> OH, MY GOD.
LET'S FIND THE [ BLEEP ] CAT.
>> NOT UNDER THERE.
>> I GOT HIM, I GOT HIM!
>> OH, NO, THAT'S BAND.
>> IT'S OKAY, JUST KEEP LOOKING.
>> GOD, WHY DID WE ASK FOR THE
SMALLEST INFECTED CAT THEY HAD?
>> MAN, IS IT IN YOUR DESK?
>> NO, IT'S JUST A STUPID DOG.
>> OH!
>> GOD, CHECK THE SHELF!
>> CHECKING THE SHELF!
NOT ON THE SHELF.
>> YAY!
>> OH, MY GOD, I FOUND HER.
>> THANK GOD.
>> YAY!
>> OH, SWEETIE.
>> THANK GOD.
YOU LOOK SCARED.
>> OH, SWEETIE.
>> BUT THE GOOD THING IS, WE
YOU LOOK SCARED.
FOUND HER.
>> BUT THE GOOD THING IS, WE
>> WAIT, WHERE DID THE CAT GO?
FOUND HER.
>> NO!
>> WAIT, WHERE DID THE CAT GO?
>> OH MY GOSH.
>> NO!
>> COME ON, COME ON!
>> OH MY GOSH.
>> ANYTHING UNDER THE COUCHMART?
>> COME ON, COME ON!
>> JUST SOME CRUMBS, A COIN, AND
>> ANYTHING UNDER THE COUCHMART?
A MAN.
>> JUST SOME CRUMBS, A COIN, AND
>> WHAT?
A MAN.
>> HEY, GUYS.
>> WHAT?
>> PAUL DANO?!
>> HEY, GUYS.
>> LAME.
>> PAUL DANO?!
>> PAUL, WHAT ARE YOU DOING
>> LAME.
HERE?
>> PAUL, WHAT ARE YOU DOING
>> GOSH.
HERE?
I'M SORRY, I'VE BEEN LIVING DOWN
>> GOSH.
THERE, RESEARCHING A NEW MOVIE
I'M SORRY, I'VE BEEN LIVING DOWN
ABOUT THREE GUYS WHO SUCK.
THERE, RESEARCHING A NEW MOVIE
COME ON, MAN.
ABOUT THREE GUYS WHO SUCK.
IT'S LIKE YOU GUYS.
COME ON, MAN.
I PLAY BEN.
IT'S LIKE YOU GUYS.
>> IT'S JUST SO CRAZY, MAN.
I PLAY BEN.
LIKE, EVERYTHING --
>> IT'S JUST SO CRAZY, MAN.
>> THE CAT!
LIKE, EVERYTHING --
>> IT'S GONE!
>> THE CAT!
>> WAS I PETTING IT?
>> IT'S GONE!
>> I'M CHECKING OUR STATS.
>> WAS I PETTING IT?
THEY DON'T SEE IT.
>> I'M CHECKING OUR STATS.
>> DAMN.
THEY DON'T SEE IT.
>> SEAN, FIND HIM!
>> DAMN.
>> HEY, GUYS, I FOUND THE CAT.
>> SEAN, FIND HIM!
>> BUY, GUYS.
>> HEY, GUYS, I FOUND THE CAT.
WHAT A CRAZY ADVENTURE WE HAD.
>> BUY, GUYS.
>> I'M GOING TO MISS THAT CRAZY
WHAT A CRAZY ADVENTURE WE HAD.
CAT.
>> I'M GOING TO MISS THAT CRAZY
>> I'LL MISS YOU, DUDE.
CAT.
>> NO!!!!!